the man accused of killing a maintenance
worker and two others at his Spring
Valley apartment appeared before a judge
today at 8 news now also learning a
report from a decade ago revealing
medical complications associated with
him 30 year old Spencer McDonald
arrested at the Rancho de montania
apartments near Flamingo and Fort Apache
this happened on Tuesday that's where a
news now reporter Ryan Matthey joining
us live on what he learned about
McDonald
yeah Brian Kirsten the Yellow Tape has
since come down from yesterday it
prevented us from even standing where
we're standing now a lot of police
activity focused on the upstairs of this
apartment building here neighbors say
McDonald had problems of his own while
his family admitted to those problems in
2013.
the court did find probable
for you or rest in this case 30-year-old
Spencer McDonald remained silent while
making his first court appearance after
accusations he murdered three people and
injured another two of the four victims
maintenance workers of the complex
performing a welfare check the other two
believed to have lived with him I never
really expect this right and I respect
is gonna happen Victor Arcee lives
directly across from the unit police
were seen Tuesday investigating for
hours actually he never talked to nobody
he just walk and I mean when you saw him
he never do like contact with with eyes
he just all the time walking like this
in 2013 The Washington Post profiled a
family with a son named Spencer battling
his schizophrenia diagnosis here's a
side-by-side comparison of then and
Wednesday the article reports that he
once swallowed three bottles of Benadryl
in a suicide attempt is not well enough
to drive and takes medication while also
undergoing electroconvulsive therapy the
Washington additionally reported his
grandmother moved in with him after his
diagnosis she was then 70 years old Ten
Years Later police described the female
victim found dead in the apartment as 80
years old he was taken into custody with
like a mace or Sledgehammer type of
object but we also have the other worker
who possibly has established to him so
wait I can't it's hard for me to confirm
anything beyond that
now police have yet to reveal how the
three deceased victims died or how long
the two found in the apartment were
killed and the biggest concern here is
why were those maintenance workers the
ones sent up for that welfare check
rather than police well we've tried to
contact the management Offices here
those calls have since gone unanswered
and a note on the front door here says
that they are now closed until Friday
reporting live near Fort Apache and
Flamingo Ryan Matthey 8 news now thank
you Ryan McDonald is facing three counts
of open murder one charge of attempted
murder being held without bail in the
Clark County Detention Center until his
next court appearance which is Monday he
also denied an on-camera interview with
our 8 news now investigators